Why do you get this extreme headache when
you work out or when you lift weights? My
head video editor, he says that after his workout
sometimes he needs to sit inside his car and wait
for 30 minutes just for the headache to go away
because otherwise he can't drive home safely.
So why does this happen?
Well, in most cases, this is called an exertional
headache, and this happens when you exert yourself
and the muscles on your head, neck, and scalp
need a lot more blood circulation so your blood
volume basically increases in your blood vessels,
which can cause a very painful headache.
Now, you need to know there's a few things
that can make this headache worse.
The first thing is not drinking
enough water, so dehydration.
Then, your DNA, meaning a history in migraines.
And if it's very hot on
the day you're working out.
Now, too much time in the sun can
also give you an extreme headache.
So let's say you go down to the beach for the day.
You spend a lot of time there.
You get burned and then you
want to go and work out.
It's not a good idea because
you will get a headache.
Another cause for headaches might
be because you have low blood sugar.
And if this is you, you might also start shaking.
You might feel dizzy - sweat a lot more - or
feel extremely hungry.
Have blurry vision,
disorientation, or even struggle to concentrate.
Now this can also happen especially when you do
intermittent fasting.
Let me explain.
So you wake up - you go through the day - you
don't eat anything - so you go through the day.
You work out.
You burn through glucose
so that gives you low blood sugar
- also known as hypoglycemia.
Another factor is stress.
Some guys, when they work out,
they're just in their thoughts and thinking
about everything you think about your
goals - obstacles - and also your problems.
If you focus on things that give you stress
all the time, you know it's good.
I also think a lot when I work out.
Sometimes we are so busy through the day we're
just busy busy busy and then when you work out,
you're in your thoughts and you're
thinking about all these things.
But, without realizing it, you might have created
a habit, where you start to focus a lot more on
the problems in your life and then you feel
stressed and you don't even realize it - that's
not good - not for you or your body.
And the warning sign that your
body will give you is a headache.
Your body has been created to be - well - amazing.
To heal yourself - to repair and build back
muscles - bigger - and so many other cool things.
And you might forget that your
body is connected to your soul.
And if it's not going good with you
psychologically, it will impact your body.
This is why so many people get sick, get a cold
when they go on holiday - because they don't
realize that they did stages in this rat race.
Work work work work work and they push themselves.
They push their bodies to the brim and the moment
they take leave from work they relax and their
body just caves in and you get sick.
The Bible says in Proverbs 17:22....
That is so true.
You know,
if you are depressed you don't feel that good.
It's going to take you a lot longer to recover.
Or, you might even get worse.
Doctors know this.
People who feel good psychologically - if you have
joy - peace - then you will recover a lot faster.
If you are stressed and if you want to
find that kind of peace that surpasses
all understanding, even in difficult situations,
then watch this video here.
And I'll see you there.
And before you go, always remember -
Life is short.
So don't waste yours.
Cheers guys.